elianto
un applauso
Buonasera Buonasera a tutti
un attimino che c'è una chitarra ancora
invisibile ora tornerà Eccola qua allora
Io qui sul copione Carlo è bianco leggo
che devo essere la cavia di un tuo
esperimento ho molta paura ti è andata
male perché di solito lo faccio in
strada e la gente se ne può anche andare
capito
Non posso scappare però va bene
[Musica]
questa cosa la so io e lo sai tu sì sono
il tuo fuori menù hai capito esattamente
il verso resta improvvisato cucinato sul
momento come se fossi chef Cracco
Cannavacciuolo due rime le prendo al
volo ma sarai tu a dovermi dare
l'ispirazione il giusto ingredienti per
questa canzone Ti farò delle domande e
io come un cazzone li infilerò dentro
questa cosa sempre restando in prosa te
lo giuro È pericolosa me la danno così
tanto non ti puoi scottare al massimo ti
piacerà gusto vado avanti perché sei un
bell'imbusto e ti vorrei domandare
ancora una volta l'avreituito Qual è il
tuo piatto preferito
la pizza
mai sentita
veramente particolare è la mia preferita
Io vivo per la pizza margherita classica
proprio cioè quindi nemmeno quella
collana NAS nemmeno quella con le
formine di Das nemmeno quella che sta
sopra non so io Eh l'altro vado avanti
il resto scaltro Comunque per continuare
a cantare Spiegami invece che cosa ti
piace mangiare quella cosa maialosa
quella che per la dieta è pericolosa
le patatine fritte col ketchup Forse era
meglio la maionese però resta comunque
Palese Ancora una volta è sempre
abbastanza di fretta la patatina fritta
dove me la frigge esattamente dentro
l'olio di palma No quello no perché
butta giù tutta la foresta pluviale
Lascia stare la canzone Te la posso
improvvisare ancora una volta per gli
amici invece quando gli vuoi bene che
cosa ti piace cucinare
il risotto al vino bianco
qua casco male
come si fa il risotto vino bianco
va bene La ricetta era facile ancora una
volta Certo Deduco ma io arrivo da
Milano cioè nel risotto Mettimi almeno
non lo so Un ossobuco No non è che lo so
buco Vabbè va bene così Grazie la
canzone è finita adesso è improvvisata
Ci vediamo dopo per la seconda portata
[Musica]
proviamo a fare sta canzone improvvisata
Stavolta ha cucinato sul momento proprio
come se fosse quello che trovo a volo
nel frigo Vi ricordo io le rime non le
scrivo quindi non offendetevi nel caso
resto e vaso dal manicomio l'ispirazione
la prendo soltanto dall'area nel naso e
vedo che per le mie rime mi hanno
portato qua due ragazze Appunto rietine
quindi del posto Rieti
norietà No quelle poliuretano ho
sbagliato ci ho preso un po' la mano dai
sto scherzando lo so perfettamente ma mi
dovete dare una mano tra l'altro siete
di estrazione molto diversa perché una è
quella cosmopolita quella che appunto si
è trasferita in quella città poco
ospitale che si chiama Milano mentre
l'altra è andata in Ghana che posto
molto più comodo dove passare una
settimana un po' al caldo e resto saldo
voglio domandarmi adesso Se non altro
cosa si mangia in Ghana
il platano il platano e quella canzone
potrebbe durare delle ore perché la
prima roba che mi viene in mente il
platano picchiatore che però è quello di
Harry Potter non c'entra niente Forse
con la banana quella verde da friggere
tutta schiacciata molto buona come
l'avresti cucinata in questa zona
d'Italia tu con magari del ragù
con dentro un po' di carota Scusami deve
una mano per la mia rimediota fatta
apposta per te che c'è la gonna
arancione Resto comunque nella canzone
invece come sarebbe stato cucinato nel
caso a Milano un Platano un picchiatore
la canzone sta durando davvero delle ore
li vuoi passare il microfono o lei dovrà
urlare Non so non possiamo fare dammi
una mano Tu piuttosto continuare a
raccontare raccontare
Allora te lo dico io il platano lo
facciamo dentro un po' che che non è
nient'altro che Un secchiello di cartone
in cui vengono messi dentro tanti
ingredienti e si dice che un piatto
hawaiano ma non è affatto così io resto
in discese ai piedi c'ho gli sci e
faccio Slalom tra le persone trovando la
giusta ispirazione per questi volti
belli Vabbè comunque siete le regine dei
fornelli possiamo dirlo cucinate
entrambe oppure no
Certo ma cose tipo al microonde però
no cose vere tipo
la pizza la pizza che non abbiamo ancora
citato questa sera un argomento
abbastanza poco mainstream il resto qui
invece tu mi pare che sei più regina del
dolciario le canzoni le faccio pure
appese al lampadario tra un sinonimo il
contrario Dimmi cosa ti viene ad alta
voce urla al tuo preferito dolce
pastiera la pastiera Milanese È un
piatto tipico delle mie zone a Corsico e
Buccinasco non la fanno da Dio grazie a
inventarmi questa canzone Grazie al
potere mio che è quello comunque di
continuare a cucinare sul momento queste
rime un po' strane canzone improvvisata
che potrebbe durare in tre settimane
l'avevo già detto tra l'altro Resto
comunque scaltro e lo posso dire Ancora
una volta non mi avete sconfitto Ma tu
per fare quel piatto lì fai anche il
soffritto No perché nella pizza non ci
va lascia stare non rispondere rimaniamo
qua vuoi dirmi il nome di una spezia un
po' strana da pronunciare così chiudiamo
la canzone
principale per voi Beh ma non è così
difficile la curcuma Aspetta adesso però
mi hai messo un po' in crisi con i tuoi
sorrisi e con questa Spezia che tra
troppo puzzolente possiamo dirlo davvero
oggettivamente no non è vero È buona
però lascia le mani tutte Gialle macchia
parecchio vado a inventarmi questa
canzone Nel frattempo il verso sarà
sempre nuovo in me vecchio e ve lo posso
dedicare a voi anche una volta se me lo
chiedi Vabbè siete voi bravissime e un
pubblico meraviglioso Rieti
[Musica]
[Applauso]